[موسيقى]
النهر الملكي كما يلقب تحيط به من كل جانب
قصور تعود بالزمن الى الوراء تحف
المعماريه تعود الى عصر النهضه تحبس
بجمالها الانفاس النهر يمنح ايضا لجميع
رواده متعه الارتماء في احضان الطبيعه
والاقتراب من تراث غير معروف نوعا انه
جميل يحتوي على مناظر خلابه هذا الهدوء
ومن تبحث عنه كاثرين
يقابل اي شخص نحن في عطله لا يوجد
اي المكان مثالي وشاعري لا يمنحنا سوى
السعاده
اننا نجد ما نبحث عنها جميل جدا
استاجرت كل منهما دراجه هوائيه لاكتشاف
المنطقه بطريقه مختلفه
دفعنا مقابل ان نتعب يكون من الجيد ان
فقدنا عشره كيلوغرامات في غضون خمسه ايام
اصبح اكتشاف الانوار ممكنا بواسطه الدراجه
الهوائيه منذ عام 2006 وانشات مسارات خاصه
لذلك على طول النهر اجواء ادخلت البهجه
لدى القرى المجاوره خاصه حين يكون الطقس
معتدلا او مشمسا في قريه بغيومون واقعه
بين مدينتي
مؤخرا مقهى خاص بمستعملي الدراجات
الهوائيه على طول النهر
قدمت من لندن الى فرنسا قبل عامين تركته
هناك 250 مقهى مخصصا لاصحاب الدراجات في
وسط المدينه وحدها بينما لم نجد الا واحده
على ضفاف الالواح
تهون نجحت اضافه الى عالم الدراجات
الهوائيه يوفر القهوه والاكل السريعه
لزبائنه
الخدمات الاجواء جميله
عبر الدراجات الهوائيه على ضفاف نهر
الالوار تجذب اكثر من مليون شخص كل عام
لكن لاكتشاف النهر توجد طريقه اخرى دون اي
مجهود او تعب في مدينه
محليه فرصه الولوج في النهر عبر هذا
القارب الذي كان قديما مخصصا لصيد سمك
السلمون ليصير بعدها في خدمه الرحلات
السياحيه بطريقه استثنائيه
عملي هنا في النهر الرائع ترى نقدم
معلومات للسياح حول نوع هذه الطبيعه وسبل
للتعايش معها وترى نقوم باكتشاف ما لا
اعرفه الى الان نرغب احيانا في السفر عبر
الطائره الى اماكن بعيده لكننا نملك اشياء
جميله تحيط بنا هنا
الاجواء رائعه انا سعيده لرؤيه الشمس
قليلا لان السماء كانت رماديه منذ قليل
نحن الان امام اشعه الغروب الجميله
وانعكاساتها الرائعه على المياه
فسحه مميزه ما كانت لتكون لولا هذه الورشه
الخاصه لصناعه القوارب التقليديه
القديمه 15 قاربا مثل هذا تمت صناعتها في
هذه الورشه منذ انشائها عام 2013
صناعه السفينه شيء خيالي نوعا ما نحن بصدد
صناعه قارب كبير وبمجرد ان ننتهي ونراه
وسط المياه ندرك حقيقه العمل الذي قمنا به
يكون ذلك اليوم تتويجا لعمل دام عده اشهر
عمل دؤوب يسهر على تحقيقه رجال ونساء
باراده كبيره من مؤسس الجمعيه
لقد علموني كيف اعمل لم اكن احسن ذلك ابدا
لقد اثروا معارف
بمجرد الانتهاء منه التحق هذا القارب
بفندق فاخر بمدينه شامبو على ضفاف النهر
طبعا
نهر يفضل البعض التمتع بسحره من خلال
التجديف عبر الزوارق
الحذاء الخاص
يرافق جون فرونسون السائحين في مغامره
خاصه لاكثر من عشر سنوات ويوفر لهم
امكانيه التخييم نحن نقوم بالتجديف لوحدنا
هذا رائع بالفعل انه شعور لم اجربه من قبل
في هذه الرحله الصغيره يكشف لنا النهر عن
جانب من حياته البريه وجزره الصغيره
المتراميه
هلا رايت السمكه هناك
نحن الان ضمن منطقه جميله جدا تحيط بها
النباتات من كل جانب ياخذ جونسون حوالي 50
شخصا في السنه في رحله منقطعه تماما عن
العالم الخارجي
كل شيء وراءهم والمجيء الى هنا يفضلون
الابتعاد عن ضغط الوقت والعمل والهروب الى
الطبيعه والهدوء
امامنا الجزيره التي ننام فيها ليست
الاولى التي في المنتصف ليست تلك على
اليمين بل الموجوده في الخلف
يسمح بالتخييم في هذه المنطقه من نهر
الالوان ينتهز الفرصه للاعتناء بهذه
البيئه
نحافظ على الغطاء النباتي هنا ونشعل الا
حطب الاشجار الميته عندما نصل الى جزيره
ما ونجد بها شيئا من القاذورات نقوم بجمع
هذه نظفا
قبل المبيت في الخيمه لا باس من بعض
النقانق المشويه سعاده ولو بسيطه تمنحها
لنا هذه الطبيعه العذراء هذا الشراب من
منطقه الى فاليد
اجل ليس بعيدا عن الطريق التي يسلكها
الحشود نحو تلك القصور هناك طريق ملكيه
اخرى يمنحها لنا النهر طريق النحو المتعه
والراحه النفسيه الخالده